DANNY HERMES: All right, it
looks like we've reached a
critical mass.
So let's get started.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Danny Hermes.
I am a member of Developer
Relations here at Google.
I don't know If you
can see that.
It says Developer Relations.
It's our nifty logo on our
documentation, if you
recognize it.
I'm the guy that supports you
all in the forum and gets your
requests to the product
teams and figures
out everything else.
I also, on the side, like to
work on the client libraries
and things like that that
make your life easier.
So I want to get started here.
We had some questions from
Caroline McLean that I want to
let her ask.
And then from there,
we'll open the
floor for more questions.
Who knows, this is may be the
shortest weekly Hangout we've
had so far, based on the
questions that I've seen
leading up to it.
But who knows.
This is also the most people
we've had at once.
So let's see how it goes.
So Caroline, go ahead and
ask your question.
CAROLINE MCLEAN: All right.
Let me start off with the first
one I think is the most
critical to us.
We are a software as a service,
and we support many,
many merchants.
And we're starting with a single
merchant and their
existing account and
information.
And the last thing we want to
do is put their account in a
bad state from testing some
of this functionality.
What's the best way to
start our testing?
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
So I don't know how much you
or your team have gotten a
chance to check out our Docs.
But our Docs at developers.googl
e.com/shopping-content are
really a great resource.
In particular, the Getting
Started page lists some
options that you have with
respect to this.
The first one is not the best
way to keep from bad things
happening, from bad
data quality.
But the first is what's called
a warnings parameter.
And if you simply append just
the word "warnings" as a query
parameter--
a query parameter with no
actual parameter value--
to the end of any API request
that you're making, then
you'll get back warnings
in the API response.
So you won't necessarily have
errors, but something where
you don't include an attribute
that we recommend, or you have
an attribute that might
be too short.
Something that's more powerful
and stronger for you as you're
testing out implementation
is what's
called the dry-run parameter.
The dry-run parameter can be
sent simultaneously with the
warnings parameter, or
it can be sent as-is.
And it's sent the exact same
way, just the keyword dry-run,
appended as a query parameter
with no query value on the end
of every request.
And when you send a request
dry-run, your inserts aren't
actually inserted, your updates
aren't actually
updated, and your deletes
aren't actually deleted.
So what happens is the server
validates the request, makes
sure it looks exactly how it
should and that it would be
accepted, and then it gives you
the simulated response.
So that is the perfect way
for you to do testing.
It is literally a sandbox,
literally a dry run.
One small caveat there.
If you try to delete or update
an item that does not exist,
the dry-run side will
not actually
tell you it's an error.
Because in order to make dry-run
fast, in order to make
it really a sandbox, we don't
actually check against your
current data for updates
and deletes.
We really just check the format
of the response, that
it will work as an update
or a delete.
But that's a very small caveat
when you're just getting
started, like you said, with
a proof of concept with the
first merchant.
I hope that is a sufficient
answer for you.
CAROLINE MCLEAN: No, that's
awesome, thanks.
I had not found--
I'm not sure I found that
set of documentation.
I'm kind of all over
the place.
We're using the .NET wrapper,
and I didn't see that in the
DLL, both the dry run
as well as the--
what was the other program?
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
So I'm actually updating--
the .NET client library is a
little behind some of the
other languages, and there are
not really good ways-- so I
checked it out.
Dry-run and warnings are
really only enabled for
queries, which doesn't
help you.
Right?
You don't care about a query,
because a query isn't actually
going to do anything to you.
CAROLINE MCLEAN: Right, it's
not going to hurt anything.
DANNY HERMES: So I'm
enabling that.
I'm changing some of
the functions.
Right now, the only signature
for the function on the
service object takes an
entry and a feed.
But in reality, we don't really
need a feed for inserting.
That might be true for some of
the other APIs in the family
of GData APIs, but in our API
it isn't that relevant.
I was not a part of the original
implementation, and I
have been submitting patches
for much of 2012.
But hopefully in the next
week or two, we'll
see a lot more patches.
And then I'm going to release
a developer's guide.
There's a developer's guide
right now for Python and Java,
to give you an idea what
it'll look like.
And there's one for PHP that'll
probably be published
this week or early next week.
And so .NET is last in line.
And it's not because
I don't like .NET.
It's just because I'm not
as good with .NET.
I don't have a working Windows
instance at work.
I have one at home, but I never
touch it, because I
prefer Linux--
sorry guys.
So I've been developing C# in
Mono on my Mac at work, and it
just takes a little longer.
But it's something I appreciate,
and it's something
I've really looked
at recently.
So I'll say for sending the
dry-run and sending warnings
parameters, you can actually
specify, using the native URL
object type-- you can actually
specify the URL in your
request explicitly.
And that may be the way
to go temporarily.
Or you could just wait until
I get this fixed out.
I don't know what your timeline
is, but I'm trying to
get this done as quickly as
possible, because I'm starting
to prepare for Google I/O, and
that's about to take up my
entire life.
So if I don't get this done
quick, it will be July 1
before it gets done.
CAROLINE MCLEAN: Oh, no.
OK.
DANNY HERMES: So did you have
any other questions?
I think you had a third
one, right?
CAROLINE MCLEAN: I think
I had multiples.
I didn't write them down,
because I gave them to you.
DANNY HERMES: I could check,
let me mute myself so you
don't hear my typing.
CAROLINE MCLEAN: No, you sent
me the answer to the other
one, which was how to support
some of those fields that are
not in the wrapper yet,
like the sale price.
DANNY HERMES: Let me address
that, for posterity and for
the other viewers.
So part of the question was,
is the sale price field in
there, and I can't
just find it?
And if it's not, what do I do?
So the answer the first question
was no, it's not
actually implemented yet
as part of the library.
It's one of the newer
attributes.
So it wasn't part of the
original implementation.
And the answer to the second
question is you can still send
it, but it has to be sent
as a custom attribute.
So in our Getting Started page,
we do describe a little
bit how to use custom
attributes.
It's in the SC namespace,
Structured Content namespace.
And the name of the attribute
is just "attribute." And you
can send units and the actual
name as a keyword, as well as
the type as a keyword, and then,
of course, you can send
your value.
So since SCP, sale price, is not
enabled, you can just send
SC attribute, with the name of
sale price, and still use
units, US dollars, or pounds,
or any other value, euros.
And then, of course, send
the dollar amount.
So that's just, like I
said, for posterity.
I'm going to let you ask your
other question, and I'm going
to actually go on mute real
quick while I type and look
for the rest of your post.
CAROLINE MCLEAN: Thank you.
Just to add to that, too, if
anybody's curious, Danny
responded to that
in the forum.
So you can see the full response
with the code sample
in the forum, if anybody
else wanted it.
I'm trying to remember what
the other one was too, so
hopefully Danny will find
it faster than I do.
Oh, I do have one that's not
on there too, which is just
one of the questions that I saw
somebody recently post was
about inventory running out.
And I think I read somewhere
that as long as when they come
to the page, it says it's out
of inventory, it's OK.
But everything I've been reading
recently says, no, get
it out of your feed ASAP.
And I'm not sure to what
degree that's critical.
Meaning if it's gone in 24
hours, is that OK, or does it
really need to be gone the
minute inventory is out,
either automagically through
the API or [INAUDIBLE]?
DANNY HERMES: I can't comment
directly on that, because I
don't specifically work
side-by-side with the Data
Quality folks, and I don't
like to comment
on that stuff anyhow.
But what I will say, it's
relatively easy for you to do.
That is the great thing
about the API.
If you're used to the feeds
files world, then in order to
change the inventory for one
product, you've got to send
your entire feed again.
But you don't have
to do that here.
So if you make some hooks, with
either your merchants
sending you new data, or if
you have some internal
tracking system, if you make
some hooks you can instantly
send the update the second
it happens, and it's no
skin off your back.
So it's something that's easy
to stay up-to-date with.
And there will be penalties
if it is out of sync.
I don't know what the
time range is.
I would say 24 hours is
reasonable, but I can't
guarantee that.
Maybe it's something that
happens on a schedule.
So if you do it at noon, and it
just so happens, instead of
having 24 hours, you
only had three--
I don't really know
how it works.
And it's something that--
it's a level of functionality
that is perfectly enabled by
the API for you to be
able to address it
the second it happens.
I do have your other
questions.
Let me zoom in on this,
so people can see.
Hopefully, that's big enough.
So you say you're relatively
new, you liked the overview--
ah, bulk inserts, and also
policy infringement errors,
and things like that.
So bulk inserts is another thing
which the more you read
the documentation, the
more you'll learn.
But we support batching.
So, what a batch is--
typically, when you send inserts
and updates you're
using the Atom entry XML element
to send everything.
So there's actually an Atom
feed element which you can
send a list of entry elements
in to do batching.
So you could send an insert,
an update, and a delete all
the same time, or you could
send hundreds of them
all the same time.
From what I hear, people who do
batch inserts, 150 products
is about the most you can get
in one batch, because
we cap it at 1MB.
But it's very easy to do bulk
inserts using batching.
But there are some
size limitations.
Your other question about
registering for--
CAROLINE MCLEAN: Danny, can
I just back you up?
Just one more clarifying
question on that.
And I'm pretty I saw on the
forums people asking to up
that limit, and it
doesn't seem like
it's an easy process.
Seems easier to try and
batch it on your side.
DANNY HERMES: It's not that's
it's a more difficult process.
It's that this API is part of a
family of APIs, and to make
a change for just us is not
really that possible.
But also, in addition to that,
you want to keep the API fast.
The average response time for
you to get your response back
from us is 300 milliseconds.
So the larger we make the
request, the longer it takes
to return those responses, A.
And B, the greater the chances
that it can drop in between,
or that some
packets can drop, right?
So it's actually more beneficial
to cap these
batches at something that's
reasonable, given the
pipelines that's sending
the data.
CAROLINE MCLEAN: I guess I
didn't realize it was a
synchronous process, too.
So everything's synchronous,
meaning you get
your immediate response?
DANNY HERMES: Yes.
And its formatted in exactly the
same way that it was sent,
except there are a few
extra attributes.
Like, we don't ask you to send
a published attribute, but we
give you back a published
attribute for when the item
was published.
So can you comment on what you
mean by how to register for
and process policy infringement
errors
programmatically?
CAROLINE MCLEAN: I saw some
event handlers, but it may
have been more in the Google
API part than the actual
Shopping API.
So I think you may have answered
it there, that maybe
when you do your batch insert,
would it come back and say,
this product is lacking, this
brand, maybe it doesn't have
this brand or it
doesn't have--
would those be immediate, or
is there some way to--
DANNY HERMES: So if it's a
required attribute, then it
will come back immediately.
And if you send an individual
request, you'll get the error
in that individual request. If
it's in a batch request and
some of the other ones succeed,
you'll still get
successes for those, and you'll
just get an error block
in the one that failed.
There is a second round
of processing,
let's say, that happens.
And in that round, some other
errors can be found.
And so there are other ways
to deal with that.
We actually have a new data
quality, feed where you can
see which items you have that
are in violation of certain
data quality policies.
CAROLINE MCLEAN: Cool.
Is there documentation on
that data quality feed?
DANNY HERMES: There is.
On the left bar, you can see
all the main topics in the
little drop-down boxes.
CAROLINE MCLEAN: Awesome.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
So I think that wraps up the
questions you have, yeah?
CAROLINE MCLEAN: I think
you're right.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
So I will stop sharing
that screen.
And I will answer Mary
Kate's question.
Mary Kate, do you not
have a microphone?
I take it she does not.
OK, she says no.
So our question in chat, for
those who can't see the chat
bar on the side, she says, "I
know you can't call within a
specific category.
I was curious if there's a way
to hone in on categories
another way.
Some areas I'm interested in
are great with queries, but
others are incredibly cluttered
with unrelated products.
It's incredibly time-consuming
to clean those areas up.
Category restriction would
be the best solution."
So this seems to be a search
API question, not a content
API question.
Is this correct?
I'm waiting for her to
respond in chat.
OK, so I will address
it shortly.
But this was mainly intended
for content
API community today.
But many of the content API
community also uses the search
API, so it's a relevant
question nonetheless.
So as you mentioned, it's not
possible to make requests by
category for the public version
of the search API--
that is, the search
API for Shopping.
So sometimes you do have
unrelated products, and that's
unfortunate.
I don't really have any solution
for you for how to
use category, other than if you
do have an idea of what
the category is, then there
relevant keywords that you can
use to strengthen your query.
And if you are able to obtain
things like a GTIN, a Global
Trade ID Number, for your items,
that can also really
strengthen your search
results.
But it's a feature we're
certainly aware of.
And it's something that
we've considered.
But I don't know that support
for searching and refining
searches by category
is something
that's going to be enabled.
So I'm sorry about that.
Yes, you're welcome.
She says thank you
in the chat.
So Andrew also--
for those who can't see the
chat-- while I was talking
about batch inserts mentioned
that you can do lots of
deletes as well in the same
batch request. Since deletes
tend to be small, you
can often get
more than 150 deletes.
Because to send a delete in
batch, you really only need
two XML attributes, one being
the attribute that says your
batch operation is delete, and
the other being the ID of the
item you're deleting.
And he's also saying you can
have more than one request
sent out at the same time.
So even if you can only send
150 items in one batch
request, you can potentially
fire off five of those batch
requests at the same time.
But there's a caveat there that
he didn't mention that I
will, that there is rate
limiting for queries per
second as well.
So if you send too many queries
in parallel, then you
may get some of them rejected
for that rate limiting.
So that wraps up all the pending
questions and comments
we have. Does anybody else
have any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Yes, I have my usual
four, approximately.
On some of these attributes,
like age group, you're showing
all lowercase letters
for those.
You want those sent
in all lower case?
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
So, the attribute names are
going to be explicit, that is,
exactly how they are in
the documentation.
You're actually referring to
the attribute name, not the
value of the attribute, yes?
AUDIENCE: I mean the value.
Because like in the age group,
you have "kids" and "adults",
or condition, things
like that.
DANNY HERMES: I believe "kids"
and "adult" are the only
accepted values there.
I don't know off the
top of my head.
Let me get back to you.
Let me write this
down real quick.
AUDIENCE: I just noticed when
I post products and when I
look at the listing in Merchant
Center, we're sending
some stuff that's got a
capitalized first letter like
it's a color or something.
And next to that, you'll see
something like age group, and
of course, I'm sending
that all lowercase.
I don't know if that
matters or not.
DANNY HERMES: I don't know that
it matters most the time.
But for something like
age group, there is a
predetermined set of accepted
attributes.
And I don't know if case
is relevant there.
But that's actually going to be
the same irrespective of if
you're using feeds or if you're
using the content API.
It's the same data quality
rules, I guess, that apply to
those values.
So I don't know off
the top my head.
I have written this question
down, and I'm going to try to
get it answered within the next
hour or two, and then
I'll post something
on the forum.
AUDIENCE: I guess maybe I was
more concerned, just because
you know how you feel like
this is customer-facing
eventually, in product
search results.
So you're just wondering, is the
customer going to end up
seeing some stuff uppercase,
some stuff is lowercase.
DANNY HERMES: So I don't believe
age group is actually
customer-facing.
I think that's more of an
attribute that enhances the
quality of our search results
and the ability to categorize
those products based
on age group.
AUDIENCE: OK, so another
thing is going back to
[? the enjoyment ?]
we have with sale price and
sale price effective.
So I looked up in product feed
specifications and they're
showing sale_price and
sale_price_effective_date.
And you say that's showing over
there in the g namespace,
but you're saying submit those
in the sc namespace?
DANNY HERMES: So the g namespace
is for if you want
to send an XML feeds file.
It's not a namespace.
And calling it g or sc is kind
of arbitrary, right?
Those are just aliases for
an actual XML spec.
But that namespace doesn't have
anything to do with the
content API.
AUDIENCE: As far as using the
.NET client library, when I
submit it, it's going to
automatically just add sc to
the tag itself, right?
DANNY HERMES: It would
if sale price were
enabled, but it's not.
AUDIENCE: I think we've done a
custom one before, so I'm not
sure what--
DANNY HERMES: I posted to the
forum with sample code.
So on each product entry, there
is an attribute called
CustomAttributes--
that's camel case, so capital
Custom, capital A in
Attributes.
And that's an extension
list property--
or I think that's what it's
called, extension something,
extension property or
something like this.
And so what you want to do,
you want to instantiate a
custom attribute object.
And there are three
constructors.
There's the constructor with no
arguments, and then you can
set the attributes after
constructing it.
There's a constructor with two
arguments, which takes a name
and a value of the attribute.
And then there's a constructor
which takes all four
arguments--
name, value, unit, and type.
So you could either use the
fourth one, and send type as
null for sale price, because
there's no type for sale
price, but there is a unit.
Or you could use the other
one, where you just
instantiate the value in the
name, and then after the fact
set the unit to whatever your
units are on your price.
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure if the
data quality people are going
to be upset with me or not,
because what I'm doing now is
I'm monitoring when an
item goes on sale.
As soon as one of my merchants
marks it on sale, I
immediately post an update with
the sale price as the
price of the item.
DANNY HERMES: That's fine.
That's perfectly fine.
Sale price and sale price
effective date are more for
local stores, for the kinds of
things that you can have via
local search and things
like that.
We don't actually have sale
price and sale price effective
date on our Docs for the
main items feed.
We really only include them
on the local products feed
documentation, but
there are many
similarities between the two.
AUDIENCE: I was just more
confused about if they go to
review the product and they
arrive on the landing page,
they're going to want
to see the price--
if the item is currently
on sale, they
want that to be reflected.
It has to be reflected either
as the price or as the sale
price inside of the effective
date, right, or they're going
to reject the product.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
And that's why a lot of times a
sale price and a sale price
effective date are more relevant
towards brick and
mortar stores, rather
than online stores.
Online stores we can just kind
of push a button and things
change, whereas brick and mortar
you at least need to go
the whole day with the price,
or usually at least.
AUDIENCE: Is it your
understanding that when we do
put the sale price and price
effective date, that we can
leave the price attribute
as the list price?
So even if we're showing
the price--
let's say we're inside the
effective date, and we give a
sale price that's lower than
list, and we leave the list
price at whatever the
regular price is.
When they arrive on the landing
page of the product,
and it reflects the sale price,
they're OK with that
list price still being entered
as the regular price, right?
DANNY HERMES: I don't know
off the top of my head.
I'll have to check with
you on that one.
I'm going to say
it's likely no.
It's likely no that that gives
you protection like that.
I think sale price effective
date is more like a
forward-looking attribute,
rather than a guard against
your current state.
AUDIENCE: So what do you want us
to submit for price, then?
Because right now it's in
the.NET client library--
DANNY HERMES: The
current price.
AUDIENCE: --That's
all it gives you.
DANNY HERMES: Submit
the current price.
So like I said, sale price
is more like a
forward-looking thing.
So let's say it goes on sale
May 5, and you want
people to know that.
That's how you would do it.
But then May 5, when the price
changes, set it to the price
that it is.
But I'll double-check
on that for you.
CAROLINE MCLEAN: Yeah, Danny,
could you post that when you
find it out?
Because that was not
my impression.
My impression was that was to
help you with rapidly changing
items, to help you
manage that.
DANNY HERMES: So, actually,
another thing that many people
in here may already know, but
you won't know yet, Caroline,
because you're new--
Well, no, it's not something
that's really--
or it's not that visible.
But we have something called
the express pipeline.
So when you send a change, when
you update a product--
not a new product-- but you're
updating an existing product,
and you change--
it's a very limited set of
attributes, like availability,
sale price, quantity,
things like that.
Things that are really easy to
validate and really easy to
check differences, it goes
in the express pipeline.
So I mentioned before there
are sort of two stages of
validation on our side.
One is the initial validation,
when we're saying whether we
accept or reject a request. But
then there's another one,
where we're sort of checking
things in more detail.
So in the case that you're only
checking the price, we're
able to bypass that second stage
of checking-- or not
bypass it, but we're really able
to speed it up, to turn
into express mode.
And in those cases,
your updates can
go in within minutes.
But for the majority of cases
it's not always like that.
But sale price doesn't enhance
or decrease the speed with
which the update is
going forward.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I guess I programmed that
right by mistake, just--
firing the current price in
"price," and as soon as a
merchant makes a change
over here, I fire it.
And then as soon as it goes off
sale price on my system, I
fire the price.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah,
that's perfect.
You have the ability to do
that because one, you're
back-end, and because, two,
the API lets you.
That's not always true
of a merchant.
But there's no reason--
if you're not limited by
computing resources, if you're
not limited by resources on our
end actually allowing you
to send it, there's no reason
not to keep your data is as
up-to-date as you
know it to be.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And number three, you ready?
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Now, this has nothing to do with
what I was working on,
but I noticed the behavior, and
I just wanted to hear your
comment on it.
When I send a product up, and
it looks like it shows a
creation date--
I'm talking about inside the
Merchant Center console--
it shows a creation date.
I think it shows maybe
an updated date.
But within like 5 minutes, or 20
minutes, or something, that
display changes and it says
"posted on." And then when I
pull an item query on it, the
updated property shows the
current date time.
So if I pull it every 15
minutes, I keep getting the
current date time in
the updated date.
Is that normal behavior?
DANNY HERMES: I've never
inspected that before.
I'm not sure about that.
This one would actually be a
question for our engineers.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't matter
to me in terms of what
I'm trying to do.
I just noticed that.
DANNY HERMES: I don't know
why that would be.
AUDIENCE: I sort of compare my
own internal last modified
product date time to the current
date time to determine
whether or not I need to
fire it as an update.
So I'm not even using Google
data to know whether I need to
update or not, I'm using
my own internal.
DANNY HERMES: Right.
AUDIENCE: OK, I just wanted
to ask that question.
DANNY HERMES: So your
application is truly RESTful.
You're not reconstructing
items on the fly, you're
actually doing GETs first before
sending them back, huh?
AUDIENCE: That's correct.
It took me two days and maybe
24 hours [INAUDIBLE].
DANNY HERMES: I admire that.
That's great.
I mean, like I said, that is
REST. Other than the fact that
we're using a POST request for
batch when we we're sending
batch requests that do more
than just insert.
But other than that fact--
it's mostly RESTful.
So the thing about it is--
and on my far right
here, Andrew at
Zazzle can tell you--
once you get to a certain
size, you
can't be truly RESTful.
It just isn't feasible.
So it's something you should
consider as you get bigger,
because it effectively doubles
the number of requests you
need to make.
Not exactly, like a delete you
probably don't need to
actually do a request, because
in order to do the request,
you need to know the item ID.
So you're not going to gain
anything to do the delete.
But for subsequent updates and
things like that, it may not
be possible to stay RESTful.
I admire it right now.
I do.
But it's something to keep in
mind. going forward, it may
not be scalable.
AUDIENCE: I did program it to
monitor the quota limits and
[INAUDIBLE]
the QPS, the re-fire.
I did all that programming.
So it'll run, like you
say, for a while--
DANNY HERMES: More power, man.
AUDIENCE: --before it starts
to break down.
The last question is, how can
I get one of those cool
Developer Relation Google
hoodies there?
DANNY HERMES: You're going to
have to come to some event we
host. I don't know off
the top of my head.
As far as I know, the only
people that have them are
people in DevRel.
They're relatively new.
But we do give swag away pretty
often, so just keep
your ear towards me, and maybe
something will come up.
AUDIENCE: Let me know.
All right, thanks a lot.
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
Any other questions?
AARON: Hey, Daniel.
DANNY HERMES: Hey.
AARON: I've got a question.
Could you elaborate on--
you talked about the
rate limiting?
DANNY HERMES: This is Aaron
speaking, I presume?
AARON: Yes, it is.
Sorry about that.
DANNY HERMES: No worries.
AARON: I work with Caroline.
DANNY HERMES: Oh, OK.
AARON: Is that the rate
applied per login?
DANNY HERMES: So you don't
really think of
it in terms of logins.
So when you send a
request, you're
signing it with a token.
So you can get tokens--
right now, there are four ways
to get tokens with Google.
You can get OAuth 1.0 tokens,
OAuth 2.0 tokens, AuthSub
tokens, or ClientLogin tokens.
I think that's all.
I highly recommend going with
OAuth 2.0, because the other
three are being deprecated over
the next three years.
So it doesn't make sense to tie
yourself to a ship that's
not going to be a
ship anymore.
I'm not going to call
it a sinking ship.
But anyway, so it's not
really about a login.
If you were referring to a
particular account, then yes,
a QPS is account-based.
And that would be like the
account that you sign in with
Google, not the merchant ID.
So if you have a multi-client
account, and you're making
requests to hundreds of
sub-accounts, but with the
same account, then all those
requests will fall under the
same limit.
The limit is not
that stringent.
It's pretty flexible.
But with any service offered
to the world, you have to
protect against
denial-of-service.
So that's just in place for
us to protect against
denial-of-service.
And if you run into it,
exponential backoff is usually
relatively easy, and a lot of
times, the QPS errors you get
go away within 15 seconds
or 30 seconds.
There is a second bit
of quota that you
might be asking about.
You have a daily quota.
And that one, if you get to a
size enough to where you're
exceeding it legitimately, just
let us know, and we will
increase it.
But if there's anything else I
didn't cover, let me know.
AARON: That's does it, thanks.
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
Yeah, I don't know if anyone
looked at the Python doc that
I just published last week.
I'm going to doubt it, based on
the number of downloads and
things like that.
But I do strongly encourage in
that doc to move to OAuth 2.0
if you're not already there.
We announced--
what is it, about
12 days ago now?
Or maybe it's 5.
Either 5 12 days ago.
I don't recall which
Friday it was now.
But we announced that OAuth 1.0,
AuthSub and ClientLogin
are all being deprecated
as auth
mechanisms, for various reasons.
OAuth 1.0 just because OAuth 2.0
is an improvement on it.
And AuthSub and ClientLogin--
well, ClientLogin is being
deprecated mostly because
keeping passwords in the clear
is never a good idea.
So like I said, you have three
years to make it there, but
it'd be nice to start
the process now.
And if people work on that over
the next two weeks and
have questions at the next
Hangout that we have on May
16, I'd be happy to talk
about them then.
So do we have any
other questions?
Andrew, any questions
from you?
ANDREW: I have a feature
request.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
ANDREW: So I love the
API dashboard.
And especially because last
week, I suddenly ran into bad
categories.
Which, I guess I was using old
categories, and they changed,
and I had to change it in the
database, and all that stuff.
But it went on like that for
two days, even though I was
having about a 40%
failure rate.
DANNY HERMES: What went
on like that?
ANDREW: Oh, I was sending
bad categories--
DANNY HERMES: Oh, I gotcha.
ANDREW: --behind the scenes.
It wasn't until somebody
noticed, actually, a decline
in linkovers that I
got to check it.
I was wondering if there would
be any way-- like there used
to be emails that would be sent,
for the feed-based ones.
So you guys could send a rate?
DANNY HERMES: This was an issue
that people on the forum
were kind of upset about.
And I just said, it's
out of my hands.
Go over to the Merchant
Center forum.
I don't know off the
top of my head.
I can update some of those
threads, if you like, and I'll
CC you on the email when
I update those threads.
I don't know off the top of my
head what they came up with,
but the team realized there
was sort of insufficient
communication going
forward for those.
So I'll let you know if they
came up with anything or what
they came up with.
ANDREW: Yeah, I was thinking--
that's a different thing.
The problem that was happening
is kind of unrelated here to
my feature request. I was
wondering if there would be
some way that emails could be
triggered at a certain error
percentage or something
on API requests.
I realize that with the
feed-based emails, that's kind
of easier for you guys.
Because as soon as the feed's
processed, you can send an
email, and it's all real
clear and synchronous.
DANNY HERMES: Without going into
too much detail, I'll let
you know that we have a big
dashboard of most frequent
requesters and things
like that.
And when people mess up
something, when people
introduce a bug, or when
people are just getting
started out, and they're doing
things, or hundreds of other
situations, we see error rates
over 90% pretty frequently.
So off the top of my head, I
don't know how much something
like that makes sense.
Maybe as an opt-in, it does.
I'll certainly toss it around
with the eng team, and see
what they have to say.
But I don't know off the
top of my head if
that's the best way.
There might be a better
way, like some sort of
account-level API,
where you can get
various stats like that.
But I don't know if an
email is the best
way to go about it.
But I hear you.
I appreciate it.
And it certainly does
make sense.
I'm surprised you don't have
a monitor for failure rate.
ANDREW: Well, do now.
But yeah, I get a lot
of random errors.
DANNY HERMES: Every programmer
assumes he never fails, right?
That's how I am, too.
ANDREW: Well, no, it's actually
the other way around.
I get a lot of 1 per 10,000,
or something like that.
And I didn't want to be
overwhelmed by those.
But I know Google is all about
statistics, and I thought
maybe you guys could have
a cool algorithm,
or something that--
DANNY HERMES: Yeah,
I'll let you know.
Like if you go from 95%
acceptance to 60% acceptance
it's kind of--
ANDREW: Yeah, I think that's
kind of Amazon's works.
Because Amazon never sends me
an email unless there's
something really bad, and then
they send something.
But there may be human
intervention on that side, for
all I know.
DANNY HERMES: I'll let you
know how that chat goes.
I'm going to open a feature
request on the external
shopping-APIs-issues list of
feature requests, and bug
reports, and things like that.
And I'll pin you with it,
so you can watch it.
All right, does anybody else
have other questions?
AUDIENCE: There's nothing
like this for Google
Checkout, is there?
They don't have a point
person like you?
DANNY HERMES: No.
There are people on my team
that support it, but
Checkout's actually being
deprecated, the API is.
And?
There are other ones
coming in place.
But I don't--
AUDIENCE: I posted something to
their code, a bug report,
and it just sits there.
It's the only issue, and
they don't respond.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah, if you want
to ping that to me, I can
push it through internally,
and see where that is.
They have DevRel, but they don't
really have dedicated
DevRel who are actively pushing
product forward, doing
Hangouts, things like that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
DANNY HERMES: But they
are on my team.
I'm part of the Commerce
umbrella.
So pretty much anything
related to Commerce I
tangentially know about,
in some way or another.
AUDIENCE: I could mention to
you real briefly, if a
customer goes to Checkout, and
let's say they're not signed
into Google.
They're going to get your
Shopping Cart in one frame,
and then in the other frame
it's going to be
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]--
DANNY HERMES: There's
an iframe, right?
AUDIENCE: --form, right?
If they hit the Back button,
it reloads the Cart only in
the upper frame, and takes
up a lot of the page.
DANNY HERMES: That's
being changed.
AUDIENCE: OK.
DANNY HERMES: The issue there
is if you do what's called a
light box--
I don't know if you're familiar
with the term in
design and development--
but a light box is--
I'm trying to think of a website
you might have seen.
A lot of times, sites
do this with ads.
When you come to their page, and
they want to show you an
ad and nothing else, they'll
put the ad in the center of
the screen, and then everything
else they put a
black transparent background
on top of.
So you can see it, but it's sort
of dark, and the thing in
the front is light.
So that's the light box.
And so what happens with light
boxes most of the time is
people use an iframe to
point to another page.
Well if you do that with
payments, then there are some
security risks that people don't
actually know what page
they're saying they're signing
in with and giving their
credit card information to.
So it's a hard problem to get
right and make really
user-friendly, and it's
something they're still
iterating on.
AUDIENCE: But you're
saying that whole
display might change?
Or that whole process
might change?
DANNY HERMES: It's something
that is not set in stone.
I don't know if it will change
or not, but it is something
they're always looking for
ways to make better, and
they're trying to think of the
best way to go about it.
AUDIENCE: I just thought maybe
not loading that in two frames
would solve that.
Load the cart, and then
load the sign-in page
below on the same page.
But, they must've had
a reason why.
DANNY HERMES: I don't know.
I don't work with that
team closely.
So I don't know what's been
decided up until now.
So it seems like that's
everything for today.
It was a nice crowd.
We even had some viewers of
the Hangout outside of the
Hangout earlier, which
may have been some of
these folks, may not.
But it's the first time we've
had external viewers, in our
third Hangout now.
So it's growing, and
I like to see that.
So thanks, everybody.
And I will see you next week.
Or, I guess two weeks.
Cheers.
AUDIENCE: Cheers.
CAROLINE MCLEAN: Danny,
thanks for your help.
DANNY HERMES: Sure thing.